[Musik]
ja ok vielen dank auch wieder ran und
also es gibt gute nachrichten und es
gibt schlechte nachrichten die gute wenn
eine ärztliche verordnung vorliegt dann
bezahlt die versicherung die reha
das ist doch fantastisch ja und die
schlechte nachricht ist dass sie in
dieser zeit möglicherweise kein gehalt
bekommen was aber passt doch krank
geschrieben
das problem ist dass sie einen
befristeten arbeitsvertrag haben der
diese woche ausläuft wenn sie nicht
arbeiten dann wird ihr arbeitgeber den
vertrag bestimmt nicht verlängern
deshalb muss er sie auch nicht weiter
bezahlen aber papa hatte mal gut
gearbeitet es gibt keinen grund
nein das ist ungerecht wir können leider
nichts machen was ist mit der
unfallversicherung mein vater hatte den
herzinfarkt doch während der arbeit
es war aber keiner druckvoll und wie
sollen unsere miete bezahlen
das kriegen wir hin
wir werden eine lösung finden